how do you feel about strip clubs strip
clubs
what should they feel about strip clubs
well it's just like jimmy used to be a
regular
at one of the ones down here knew all
the strippers
and you like sleep with them why would
you tell her this
yara met up with jovi's friend sarah to
get their nails done
and i don't know if it was the champagne
they were drinking or what
but sarah she just aired all of jovi's
dirty laundry he was you know
always out having a good time till 3 a.m
drunk i mean like not know where he was
at or what happened the night before
well damn it doesn't seem like she wants
her friend's
relationship to work that's what it
seems like
we'll get to yara's reaction about what
sarah said
in just a few plus we're gonna take a
look at
ziad's reunion with rebecca which
was a bit awkward after 18 hours of
flying
he was surprised at the airport with not
just rebecca
but two people who have their suspicions
about him
but he does just seem very nonchalant
he's just like yeah okay
yeah okay i don't know like i can't
really explain it he
thought he would be a lot more
enthusiastic once he got here yeah
it's kind of like it's feared
how you doing 90 day fans fam it's
melisia
let's go ahead and jump into the biggest
must-see moment
from the latest episode of 90 day fiance
starting with yara's nail date with
jovi's long time
friend sarah now if we back up to the
top of the episode
yara went with jovi to the airport
before he headed off to guyana
for work as they said goodbye to one
another
i realized they need to miss each other
more often
because it was the first time the
first time that i've seen genuine love
between them
they look like they liked each other all
right i'm gonna go
now
what i'm gonna miss you so much
so much how much something good how much
a dollar
dollars i miss you too
i'm bad love you bye
goodbye
[Music]
all right baby i'm going out on my
flight
sweet right it was so sweet oh i'm a
sucker for love
i know they have their moments but i
might need to start rooting for this
couple
well now that jovi is gone for four
weeks
his friend sarah stepped in to entertain
yara for the day
and mind you this was the first time
they met
so i think it's important that yar knows
who the man is she's about to marry
and i feel like everyone needs to be on
the same page and they both need to be
ready
so um do you think jovi's ready to like
settle down
and whatnot cause i know like the jovi
before yara and he was
you know always out having a good time
till three am drunk
i mean like not know where he was at or
what happened the night before
that's crazy that sounds for me like not
about joey
i bet if jovi knew that sarah was gonna
say all of this
he would not have called her up to hang
out with his fiance do you remember
the first time we met sarah and her
husband
it was during episode 1 of this season
and they both were skeptical about
jovi's relationship with yara
in their minds they already came to the
conclusion
that it was going to fail so it seems as
if
sarah took that same energy into meeting
yara
by highlighting and focusing on all the
reasons
jovi won't be a good partner instead of
reasons
why he might how do you feel about strip
clubs
street clubs what should they feel about
stream clubs well it's just like jimmy
used to be a regular
one of the ones down here knew all the
strippers
and you like sleep with them
that's the part of the joy of what he
didn't tell me about to you he's
probably completely different of course
i mean if i if he will be party guy i
would just not be with him and i think
he would understand for this he stopped
to do all these things right
no i wouldn't want that i mean does
sarah even
like jovi i know she said she thinks
it's important that yara knows the man
she's about to marry
but i don't necessarily agree with her
approach
so even though sarah thinks she knows
jovi
she might need to take a step back and
give him the benefit of the doubt maybe
he has
changed maybe
i didn't know why sarah tells me all
these bad things about jovi maybe for
her just funny
i don't know
[Music]
so many things with sarah say it was
kind of embarrassing i was like oh my
goodness who is this person about who
she is
talking because i know joey from
different side
and i always just start to thinking did
i lie to myself did i really don't
so that he was kind of a party guy and
have this all interesting past
or i was just not paying attention i
don't know
well yara time will tell
time will tell all right let's move on
to ziad's awkward arrival in america
just a refresher rebecca and zied
connected
online before she traveled to tunisia
to meet him during her time there they
clashed over
major cultural differences including the
fact
that ziad doesn't approve of other men
around rebecca
even if she isn't romantically involved
with them now after anxiously waiting
the 49 year old is bringing her 27 year
old fiance
to georgia on a k1 visa given the fact
that my daughter tiffany and her fiance
micah
haven't been exactly supportive of the
relationship
it means a lot to me that they want to
be with me today at the airport to meet
zed does it look good do i like do i
look good
yeah will you fix my makeup right there
calm down you calm down you calm down
he doesn't know you're coming and he's
not gonna know that we're riding back
too
you're not yeah we are if i was tiffany
i would do the same thing
let's not forget rebecca has gone down
this world before
with her ex-moroccan husband who was
younger than zied
he basically used her and according to
tiffany
she crashed and burned after that so yes
i would be chaperoning my mother too i'm
losing my mind
[Music]
oh once they got to the airport
rebecca was so nervous that she could
barely stand
but then enters the ed
oh my god
baby you look amazing
oh my god
[Music]
are you okay yeah
oh don't worry about it baby oh my god
you smell so good you look so good
oh my god was i the only one waiting on
him to compliment her back
she came in full force oh baby you look
so good
you smell so good and he didn't say a
thing
i know you're nervous yet but come on at
least say thank you
you want to meet them get your stuff
okay hello
this is died tiffany how are you
doesn't he smell amazing i'm in person
michael yeah let's meet mike okay i say
hi for micah
he's on purse duty
[Music]
thank you micah was not trying to fake
any sort of excitement and i don't blame
him
in a previous episode rebecca told him
that even though he is her daughter's
fiancee
zied might have a problem with him being
around her
all because zied doesn't like other men
around his woman so of course
that just rubbed micah the wrong way
this is about to be his mother-in-law
i'm sure to him
that just sounded weird something else
that i noticed
was that zied was really short with his
words
once again i don't know if it was the
nerves
or maybe he was just tired but he kept
saying the word
perfect everything was perfect are you
okay
yep good perfect yeah i wanted to come
and get you myself
only but she told me today i'm coming
with you
yeah that's so good yeah perfect
we're here yeah perfect
is it ziad because your face is saying
otherwise
at this point he is obviously
uncomfortable
and rebecca's daughter tiffany is very
concerned about her mom
she feels like she just completely let
her guard down
and she's love struck over zied fast
forward to dinner
which zia didn't want to go to but they
went anyway
tiffany and micah cut straight to the
chase
what do you plan on doing for work
like job what i work
yeah i think uh
i network six months after the marion
yes but what do you plan on doing
uh ma i don't know well we her ex did
not like
work so that's why i'm always going to
be nervous
we will always have concerns because it
is
totally different than anything we're
used to been through before
it ended badly y'all are living together
something
is going to come up then we will have
problems
yeah yeah i think i ended up okay
thankfully ziad did not look like he had
the energy
to go back and forth because the last
thing i want to see
is him and micah get into it
that would be intense intense
intense all right well next week
rebecca faces a new issue after zead
reveals
that he wants to go back home
i miss my family my friends maybe i
go see them again if ziet isn't happy
here i
don't know if this marriage will even
happen
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t
because as usual we are covering it all
i'll see you next time
[Music]